well we mentioned Awards uh because you
killed it the Oscars uh jely posted this
photo last year at the Golden Globes oh
yes first of all no no from this from
this photo alone we could be friends
like that is my level of energy so the
thing that was amazing about the moment
is this is about Michelle yeah and I
love her and it was a really important
moment for her and it began uh what
became obviously a great year for the
movie and Michelle particular um and
remember this is a woman who's 60 years
old who's been doing this for a long
time yeah and that was a big moment and
what happened from that moment was that
a a a meme a woman named Aaron Gallagher
on social media on social media posted
what she felt from the picture I mean I
just that wasn't like I didn't pose for
that picture it's not even a
particularly nice picture of me it looks
like you're in a game like what well
you're not at a Cowboys game but you're
no sorry about that so sorry everybody
but but I'm I'm in the moment and what
she was talking about was hype women
that women need to Hype other women I
think we do that I think they just don't
show that well but what she was saying
this was like a really evident moment
where a woman was hyping another woman
and we as women need to do more of that
and she created not I didn't I became
like the like unofficial spokesperson
she created an entire movement hyp soci
media if you want to go and follow hype
women you'll you'll see that it's just
an important thing for women to do with
each other because there's a difference
between the word support and hype
because you know people always say
support women I think that you should
have support everyone as well but I just
mean when you say hype women like hyping
is different it's more of like you're
really like an advocate for them and you
are really like you're wanting them to
get their flowers like you're energy and
you know uh the world is difficult and
we all need to support each other and so
um especially those huge moments you
said she'd been waiting like years you
know well but it was that it was the
beautiful part of that here's a woman
who I did the movie because Michelle yo
was in it like when they sent me that
weird script believe
me yeah it was a lot going on I did the
movie for two reasons yeah number one
Michelle yo was going to play Evelyn
yeah number two it was shot in Los
Angeles
and I live in Los Angeles yeah and I
never work in Los Angeles and so for me
to have a job that was in Los Angeles I
thought was worth
[Music]
[Applause]
doing thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home